but this importance in fact stems from
ignorance of the nature of mediation and
of absolute cognition itself for
mediation has nothing beyond self moving
self sameness or is reflection into self
the moment of the eye which is for
itself pure negativity or when reduced
to its pure abstraction simple becoming
the eye or becoming in general this
mediation on account of its simple
nature is just immediacy in the process
of becoming and is the immediate itself
reason is therefore misunderstood when
reflection is excluded from the truth
and is not grasped as a positive moment
to the absolute it is reflection that
makes the true and result but it is
equally reflection that overcomes the
antithesis between the process of its
becoming and the result for this
becoming is also simple and therefore
not different from the form of the true
which shows itself as simple in its
result the process of becoming is rather
just this return into simplicity though
the embryo is indeed in itself a human
being it is not so for itself this it
only is as cultivated reason which has
made itself into what it is in itself
and that is when it for the first time
is actual but this result is itself a
simple immediacy for it is self
conscious freedom at peace with itself
which has not set the antithesis on one
side and left it lying there but has
been reconciled with it
there's a lot going on in this
particular paragraph number 21 and Hegel
is starting off by talking about
mediation permit law which we've
mentioned already here he's going to
give us a much more clear
characterization of it I think that
there can be a problem with this this
passage in taking what he says here as
providing us with the once-and-for-all
definition of mediation because there's
more to it than than he's telling you
here but what he is doing at least is
telling us some things about what he
means by this concept and why it's so
important so with that in mind let's
let's look at what he actually says he
says that mediation he's got two ways of
characterizing this one in terms of the
self and identity and one in terms of
this process of reflection which is a
negative process as we've seen it
becoming other so already there's a to
full becoming other nasir right there's
on the one hand self moving self
sameness and concealed within that is
the fact that in order for it to be self
same there already has to be a kind of
duality involved in order to be same to
myself in order to be identical to my
own identity I have to set up my
identity I have to posit it as something
over here which then I am and then I can
ask myself the question well what the
hell is this I over here is it just that
over there why is it over here and we
can we can frame this in a number of
different ways so already in this this
formulation there's a bit of all Terra T
concealed here clearly there's already
alterity as soon as we start thinking
about what the terms reflection means
for Hegel and this process of reflection
into self mediation is both of these
what's really interesting about the
yes that I think is worth pausing and
and reflecting on again upon there is
that when we think of mediation when we
think of media things in in the middle
something mediating another thing we
tend to think about these as if we've
got a over here and B over here and then
the thing in the middle and the thing in
the middle is a third type of thing so I
talked to you I'm a person you're a
person through the medium of this camera
that I'm looking at you're not seeing
the camera you're only seeing what the
camera is actually showing you so
there's already like four terms there
why is the camera there because I have
set it up in order to film me going out
to you so in a way the camera although
it is you know a device it's something
separate for me it's in a way an
extension of me so that I can reach you
then I think gives you a bit of a
conception of what Hegel's trying to get
at here mediation is not just bringing
in a third term it involves the thing
that is expressing itself unfolding
itself acting engaging in this self
moving south so sameness in the process
of reflection into itself in the process
of becoming other to itself in the
process of recovering that alterity and
overcoming the antithesis so he says
this is what people don't want to get
because this is really messy and sticky
and hard to grasp so they'd rather have
things be immediate just straightforward
the problem is is that reality doesn't
work that way
and so whenever you're doing that you're
hiding the fact that you're actually
mediating things all the time
when you're doing that and you're hiding
from yourself that very the very process
that you're doing but you're also
setting things up in such a way as to
only inadequately grasp the realities
that you're trying to grasp so he says
the I are becoming a general this
mediation on account
of its simple nature is just immediacy
in the process of becoming so we can
look at this in an abstract way it's
just a matter of the comedy and when we
talk about becoming it seems like well
we're talking about something that
doesn't really have any being being and
becoming our opposed to each other
becoming is always the you know the one
that loses out it's not as good
analogically hinkel's saying that's what
we call the immediate but that's really
quite a stress what we wanted to take
hold on what we want to think about is
the absolute or the true itself and what
we're not getting a lot of the time is
that this is not something simple that
it already involves a process of
reflection and reflection involves all
these things that we've already talked
about alienation here he actually talks
in terms of reason reason itself is
something dynamic this is really
important because if human beings are
the rational animal we're never fully
rational until we reach the end of our
development for Hegel and the very
process of realizing how we're
irrational is a growth or at least a
potential growth in rationality we do
that by reflection so when I realize man
I let my anger get away with me and that
turns me into a dummy and then I do
things that are irrational that's a very
concrete example of this process of
reflection which involves negation you
know saying that's bad I shouldn't be
like that and then that allows the
possibility of transcending them going
beyond of incorporating these lessons
that we learn so he says it's reflection
that makes the true a result but it's
equally reflection that overcomes the
antithesis between the process of
becoming right and
the result
the thing that we want to look at
because this becoming is all so simple
and therefore not different from the
form of the true which shows it as
simple in its result so it's through
reflection which is medians which takes
place through this process of becoming
of it through this process of being okay
with everything not being totally
wrapped up in a bow not being totally
clear things not being as simple as you
expect them to requiring a process of
inquiry of activity on your part it's
through this process of reflection that
we're able to bring all the parts
together what that means is at least
until we reach the end we're never going
to be completely finished the results
that we have along the way our stopping
points where we could get stuck they
could become cul-de-sacs but there's
also going to be a beyond where we say
oh man there's still other things to do
this is going to happen through through
history of course it's not as if any one
single person until of course Hegel
thinks that they can like jump through
all of this stuff and Hegel can only do
it because mankind humanity has worked
this out painfully laborious ly through
suffering the patience of the- over the
course of time so he gives this example
the process of becoming is returning to
simplicity says the embryo is indeed in
itself a human being but it's not so for
itself reflection isn't taking place yet
and it's not just with the attaining of
rationality Hegel says that one becomes
a human being he says it's only as
cultivated reason which has made itself
into what it is in itself that is when
it for the first time it is actual this
result is itself a simple immediacy self
conscious freedom at peace with itself
which is not just set the antithesis
over there and so I'm not going to think
about that
but is actually reincorporated
reintegrated that with itself that's
what it means to be at least at this
point in the state in the game to be
fully rational to be cultivated reason
according to Hegel
what has just been said can also be
expressed by saying that reason is
purposive activity the exultation of the
supposed nature over a misconceived
thinking and especially the rejection of
external teleology has brought the form
of purpose in general in to discredit
still in the sense in which aristotle
too defines nature as purpose of
activity purpose is what is immediate
and at rest the unmoved which is also
self moving and as such is subject its
power to move taken abstractly is being
for itself for pure negativity the
result is the same as the beginning only
because the beginning is the purpose in
other words the actual is the same as
its notion only because the immediate as
purpose contains the self or pure
actuality within itself the realized
purpose or the existent actuality is
movement and unfolded becoming but it is
just this unrest that is the self and
the self is like that immediacy and
simplicity of the beginning because it
is the result that which has returned
into itself the latter being similarly
just the self and the self is the
sameness and simplicity that relates
itself to itself
we need to be careful in approaching
this section not to be too hasty to read
into what he's talking about as reason
for normal in terms of our own
rationality or our theories about what
reason is for human beings now you you
could object and say well Hegel himself
and trying to discern what reason is for
the absolute and then then perhaps talk
about reason and human beings he's he's
a human being himself so he's using
reason lowercase R to understand reads
an uppercase R there is there's a
certain you know
circularity or reflexivity involved
there that is worth noting
so he says reason can be understood as
purpose of activity all of what's been
said here can also be expressed here's
another way of saying it by saying that
reason is purpose of activity its Veck
message that is activity which is
oriented towards ends by finding means
by being the means messia oriented
towards it measured to it we might even
say determined to it so he's gonna say
two things here that are particularly
important he's not going to really
explore what that means to be purposive
that's going to come much later as a
matter of fact there's an entire section
of the phenomenology that's called
reason where we're going to explore this
in great detail he says the first thing
is there's been a sort of reaction in
modernity against the concept of purpose
and why well because people who were
talking in terms of
or final causality or teleology we're
giving things a bad name I mean all you
have to do is read somebody like
Voltaire's Candide and and you'll see
the sort of thing with Pangloss you know
eyeglasses it's so fortunate that you
know God designed the nose and the ears
in such a way as to be able to support
my spectacles there were some people who
looked at that final causality in those
sorts of ways and they you know they
they made it possible to sort of parody
and say that's not really gonna work and
so you see people like Descartes and
Hobbes and you know many of the natural
scientists of the time saying we got to
get rid of these these Aristotelian
notions of causality the final causality
the purpose of thing we can understand
that in terms of maybe intentions or you
know subjective preferences or pick
whatever you like but but really is
especially in the world of nature we got
to get rid of this conception of final
causality especially for physical things
so Hegel says yeah some some of some of
the way and people thought about this is
has brought the form of purpose and
general and to discredit he says but in
the sense in which Aristotle too defines
nature as purpose of activity purposes
what is immediate and at rest the
unmoved which is also self moving and as
such is subject so he's saying look era
still have got this right and actually
other people who are following Aristotle
like you know the Scholastic's like
Leibniz talking about you know the need
to reintroduce final clauses would be
getting this right as well that the
nature of a subject is to engage in
purpose of activity it may be that not
all nature actually has this the way
that we thought it does but human beings
are certainly interjecting this into at
least their portion of existence so so
far so good
so then he says it's power to move taken
abstractly as being for itself for pure
negative
but we don't want to remain with the
abstract right never do so the result is
the same as the beginning only because
the beginning is the purpose so when
we're engaging in this dialectical
unfolding or unpacking of what the
beginning is leading up to the result
you can say that purpose of activity is
going to be the means by which we get
from beginning to result and remember
we've just talked about the whole and
true as being a result as being for this
process of becoming other becoming other
again and overcoming that become
together but all of this would actually
be understood as having some sort of
teleology behind it and you know to give
away the the spoiler what is that
teleology for God through us or the
absolute through us or reality or the
true or the good through us and through
human history to come to fully know
itself in its fully developed condition
that is as us now does the screwed up
human being that buddy actually turned
out to be but as as the dynamic whole
that encompasses all of them but that's
going way far ahead so he says the
realized purpose is movement and
unfolded becoming it's just this unrest
this this process the dynamic process
that is the self and the self is like
that immediacy and simplicity at the
beginning because it is the result that
which is returned into itself and so
this is the this is the the process of
becoming of development and it's going
to be inhabited throughout the entire
thing by this purpose by having some
sort of teleological structure to it
that doesn't mean I know I gave away the
spoiler but that doesn't mean that early
on we actually know what the hell were
it we're doing or what it is that Spirit
is trying to
blush the matter-of-fact of Hegel's
wrong about where it went
we still don't hope you know what it was
trying to accomplish but we do know that
it is purposive and we do know that
thereby we can sort of like explore that
and unpack that and look at our own
involvement in it and figure out what
the absolute is trying to do through the
process of history
the need to represent the absolute as
subject has found expression in the
propositions God is the eternal the
moral world order love and so on
in such propositions the true is only
posited immediately as subject that is
not presented as the movement of
reflecting into itself in a proposition
of this kind one begins with the word
God this by itself is a meaningless
sound a mere name it is only the
predicate that says what God is gives
him content and meaning only in the end
of the proposition does the empty
beginning become actual knowledge this
being so it is not clear why one does
not speak merely of the eternal of the
world moral world order and so on or as
the ancients did of pure notions like
being the one and so on it is short of
that which gives the meaning without
adding the meaningless sound as well but
it is just this word that indicates that
what is posited is not a being that is
something that merely is where essence
or a universal in general but rather
something that is reflected into itself
a subject but at the same time this is
only anticipated the subject is assumed
as a fixed point to which as there
support the predicates are affixed by a
movement belonging to the knower of this
subject and which is not regarded as
belonging to the fixed-point itself yea
it is only through this movement that
the content could be represented as
subject that the way in which this
movement has been brought about is such
that it cannot belong to the fixed point
yet after this point has been
presupposed the nature of the movement
cannot really be other than what it is
can only be external
hence the mere anticipation that the
absolute is subject is not only not the
actuality of this notion but it even
makes the actuality impossible for the
anticipation posits the subject as an
inert point whereas the actuality is
self movement
section 23 is one that I think is
particularly clear and easy to follow
but I'm going to lead you through it
anyway because perhaps maybe it isn't
so let's actually look at what he is
saying to begin with I want to note an
ambiguity and a sort of transition
that's taking place here he says the
need to represent the absolute as as
subject now we've talked about why it's
important to not only understand the
absolute in substance but as subject and
what do we mean when we say subject well
that can mean more than one thing so
before we were talking about the
absolute as subject as you know being
like like us we're subjects and we act
upon or acted upon by objects or by
other subjects we have a certain agency
we are as Aristotle says self movers
Hegel loves that idea and the absolute
itself the totality that we're all
within is also a subject in that sense
but we can also talk about subjects in
terms of grammar and in terms of logic
the subject you notice a subject verb
object we can also say subject copula
predicate and it's that sense that that
Hegel is going to be playing off here so
he says the the need to represent the
absolute of subject has found expression
in propositions like God is X where X
could be the eternal the moral world
order love and they is etc you know
whatever it is that you want to throw in
there you could even take you know stuff
that sort of anti theistic though God is
the worst idea anyone ever came up with
God is the big guy in the sky God is the
Flying Spaghetti Monster God is a
figment in the imagination of theists
worldwide no matter what you're doing
you're carrying out the same process
that Hegel is talking about
here where you're giving this some sort
of content by what you have fix after
the is so he says the word God by itself
is a meaningless sound a mere name it's
only the predicate that says what God is
even if the predicate is just is you
know say God
it has necessary being or God so the
very nature of God to exist that would
be you know that's what Hagel will make
out of the ontological proof at a
certain point that would be to say that
is becomes the predicate that tells you
what this thing over here is otherwise
you might just say Google it would let
you know or make up some others sound
genki genki you know you could put
anything you like over here it's what
matters what matters is gonna be what
you put on this side so he says the
predicate gives content and meaning only
at the end of the proposition does the
empty beginning become actual knowledge
so we say for example God is the
absolute sounds good now we know what
God is sort of what the hell is the
absolute well and the absolute is God
you see once God God is the absolute
there's some things that if we stick in
there it's going to be you know rather
circular as a matter of fact if you
think about it you know I am what I am
or I am Who the one who is you know from
Exodus would not be particularly helpful
at this stage in the game other than to
say you know that God is like full the
fullness of being or something like that
but we still don't have a good
conception of what that means yet so
notice that mediation has come in here
the predicate mediates the subject for
us it helps us understand what the
subject is supposed to be so he says
only at the end of the prep the
proposition is the empty beginning
become actual knowledge now
this is the case he says it's not clear
why you don't just speak merely of the
eternal of the moral world order and so
on or as the ancients did of pure
notions like being the one and so on in
short of that which gives the meaning
without adding the meaningless sound as
well so one thing you can do is to say
all right get rid of this now we're just
going to focus on this but then there
pose of the problem great what's that
that no matter what we pick whether it's
the one the the form of the good the
eternal you know the Eternity itself the
moral world order whatever we're going
to pick that's going to be an absolute
we're gonna run into this issue so he
says it's just this word that indicates
what is positive is not a being that is
something that we can just encounter
something that merely is or essence or
universal in general but rather
something that is reflected into itself
a subject and now notice we've shifted
back from the subject of a predicate to
which where is that mediation taking
place through the predicate to something
which is now reflected into itself the
subject has agency the process of
reflection the realization of its own
negativity and this sort of thinking
about its room magnetically sucking in
the predicate this process of reflection
once it becomes self-aware enough
realizes that it makes sense of the
subject through the predicate so it also
begins to realize the problems with this
subject predicate form itself is the
subject like Hegel says really a fixed
point on which we can hang all these
predicates sort of like you know I'm a
fixed point on which we have a tie and a
jacket and a shirt and an undershirt and
pants you know we can go down the list
you know glasses here
skin start getting under that muscle
bone start taking away all these things
it's sort of like peeling an onion it's
not that that Hagel wants to do is the
move though he wants to say look the
nature of subjectivity not only for us
human beings but for the subject that is
the absolute that is God that is the
divine that is all these are the great
things works itself out through this
process of positive of others mediation
that's what's going on here so he says
it's only through this movement that the
content could be represented as subject
the way in which this movement has been
brought about is such a cannot belong to
the fixed point so the mere anticipation
that the absolute is subject is not only
not the actualities of this notion it
even makes the actuality impossible it's
what is showing us here is how to avoid
a dead end for the anticipation posits
the subject as an inert point whereas
the actuality is self movement if we
want to think about God substance being
itself whatever it is we want to put in
that top slot where spirit is going to
go it's got to be something that is
intrinsically active self uttering
working through mediation and it has to
do so through these predicates for
positing that then reveal something new
about the subject so the subject is not
merely in a nerd point that we take for
granted but something that discovers
itself on the way